but we begin this morning with the
Memphis Police Department releasing
video of the beating death of Tyree
Nichols the 29 year old father and FedEx
worker whose family says he was a
beautiful soul with a creative eye was
on his way home from taking pictures of
the sky when police pulled him over on
January 7th the disturbing video from a
surveillance camera and police body cams
shows officers tasing nickels tackling
him to the ground and striking him
repeatedly with their boots their batons
as he wails screams for his mother and
cries I'm just trying to go home Nichols
died three days later after the footage
was released protesters took to the
streets of Memphis and other cities
Across the Nation the five fired Memphis
police officers are out on bond after
being indicted on several charges
including second-degree murder and
kidnapping Elise Preston is in Memphis
with more Elise good morning
Dana good morning to you the family of
Tyree Nichols says there was no Humanity
in the beating of the 29 year old who at
6-3 weighed just 150 pounds we have to
warn you some of this footage is
disturbing
29 year old Tyree Nichols worked for
FedEx was an avid skateboarder lived
with his parents and wore a tattoo with
his mother's name on his shoulder my son
loved me to death and I loved him to
death we just had a special bond he was
the baby you know but after Police
Stopped to him body cam footage recorded
on January 7th shows what happened next
Nichols runs off
but then officers apprehend him this
took place less than 80 yards from his
mother's home he called out for her to
help him
[Applause]
mom for some three minutes Memphis
police officers punched kicked and are
seen hitting him with a baton even after
he was restrained the video then shows
the officers talking about what happened
and failing to administer medical health
for more than 20 minutes two fire
department paramedics were there with
medical equipment for at least 10
minutes
Nichols died three days later in the
hospital they were just a beautiful soul
just a beautiful soul the five officers
involved have already been fired and
faced felony charges including
second-degree murder aggravated assault
and aggravated kidnapping this is the
blueprint going forward
for any time any officers whether they
be black or white
will be held accountable lawyers for two
of the former officers said their
clients will plead not guilty he could
not be more upset about this entire
situation to be accused of being
involved in the death of another is
devastating nichols's mother rovonne
Wells said she could not watch the video
they always say no parent should ever
have to bury a child what does it feel
like to bury your son after losing him
in this way
I have no words for that
I am still
trying to wrap my head around all of
this I'm still in disbelief really it
has not hit me
at all it this has not hit me and I know
it hasn't but again I have to stay
strong because I have other children
this release of the video last night too
Shelby County deputies have also been
relieved of Duty pending an internal
investigation the sheriff says after
seeing the video for the first time he's
concerned those deputies violated policy
Michelle
Elise thank you well the video release
has prompted mostly peaceful protests
Nationwide where many are demanding
Justice for Tyree Nichols and calling
for better policing demonstrators
marched across a bridge that joins
Tennessee and Arkansas to demand the
Memphis Police Department disband the
Scorpion unit that's the one that the
fire police officers were all a part of
at least three people were arrested
after someone smashed the windshield of
a police car during protest in New York
City's Times Square and in Los Angeles
police say someone threw a smoke bomb
and an at an LAPD vehicle as crowds
protested outside Police Headquarters
more rallies are planned Nationwide this
weekend Memphis Police director CJ Davis
describes the officer's actions as
heinous Reckless and inhumane Davis says
she could only stomach watching the
video Once in an interview with our Jeff
pigays Davis says she still doesn't
understand why the officers went so far
yes very puzzling for me that I don't
have the information that I need to at
least understand what started this it
started at a 10. you know from the
moment they got out of their cars
and that piece I've never seen before
the similarity for me with Rodney King
and I was an officer back during that
time too
that came to mind for me on this video
to me there was a level of group think
you know that there was no one that you
know isolated themselves or stepped out
to say stop we got him or whatever the
case is that's enough
Davis added more questions to the
investigation pointing out that one of
the officers failed to turn on their
body camera and that the officer that
made the initial traffic stop did not
call it in over the radio
President Biden spoke with Tyree Nichols
parents over the phone and offered his
condolences ahead of the public release
of that video in a statement the
president said he was outraged and
deeply pained to see the horrific video
Mr Biden added while the footage will
leave people justifiably outraged he
joins the Nichols family in calling for
peaceful protest